kova 19 continues to affect las vegas
with yet another strip property changing
its hours thank you for joining us at
five i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm denise valdez so starting next
year the mirage will
only be open from thursdays at noon
until mondays at noon
arc mana joining us now live from the
mirage to explain why and also how
tourists are reacting to the news orca
denise and kirsten the mirage is the
latest resort here on the las vegas
strip
to reduce its hours and experts say it's
because of lower demand
during the coven 19 pandemic now
starting on january 4th
2021 the mirage will only be open from
noon on thursdays to noon on mondays the
property says the temporary change to
their hours of operation
will include the casino floor
restaurants and all other resort
amenities
mgm resorts which owns the mirage had
already announced midweek hotel closures
at the mirage
mandalay bay and park mgm back in
november
tourists on the las vegas strip tell us
while they understand
why properties like the mirage are
closing on certain days
they think they should stay open i think
that's only going to drive
his business away i mean people want to
be here now more than ever because i
mean this is one of the only places you
can enjoy now
it may be wrong that we came but i mean
we're actually taking precautions you
know we're taking care of ourselves
on the other hand experts say there is
lower demand at las vegas strip
properties
because a lot of people just don't feel
that safe flying on a plane
or staying at a hotel during the
pandemic pandemic now experts add that
it's
also hard to predict when people will
feel more comfortable or when
conventions could come back so it's
unclear
when exactly these temporary closures
will be lifted
there is some good news though we can
expect some changes maybe sooner rather
than later
because the vaccine has started to be
administered reporting live on the las
vegas trip tonight orca manna 8 news now